hey world Jeff clima here from new media
rock stars I'm about to skype with Alex
day he's a YouTube musician he's also a
vlogger kind of a podcaster guy wears a
lot of hats long story short I'm it's
super excited to talk to him and find
out just what the hell is going on in
his world so hey Alex how's it going
hello my name is alex day I just broke
one of my guitar strings while tuning
and but I'm going to trip up and your
song with the other five this is called
forever yours we sink together of King
although we try it seems we just can't
find our harmony we just don't fit each
other's frequencies that makes you out
of reach and I am finally accepting that
about you and me it's plain to see we
only ever want to stay inside and watch
TV because that shot that's good a
memory you're just good company and I'm
finally accepting that another time when
we stole a whole day everybody knows
took it away and it will be forever mine
and it will be forever you can we are
not an economy undone you'll never
forget how feel to be on God it will be
boy online and it will be forever yours
come on darling of something decency you
know there's nothing you can say that
would embarrass me I heard a stop tell
me the talk is cheap but it's all you do
with me and I'm finally accepting that
it's just our routine we try and dream
and buy the things we said we buy when
we got more money all in the name of
memories that's what you were with me
and I'm finally accepting my google
number one who stole the whole day
nobody knows it to get away and it will
be Dora fun line and it moving former
player now we are not at a comfy on sun
will never forget our feel to be on
golden will be falling but mine and it
was a funny nose it took it away and it
will be forever mine and it will be for
a but that he does now we own the night
and it can't be undone will never forget
how it feels to be of God it will be
fallible mine and it will be forever
yours this will be gone this will be
nice and I'm glad you opened up with
with Forever Yours there because it's
this song has such a cool backstory to
it of how it kind of jumped onto the UK
pop chart and I don't want you to tell
the whole story because it's I mean it's
a crazy big long story with a lot of
twists and stuff but give me I'm just
gotta give us our viewers like the sum
up of what happened with that okay yeah
so I'm releasing music for about three
years and I had two albums out and then
after my second album was like I just
want to focus on on making one really
good song and instead of trying to do
ten so
so I went into dome recorded three or
four things and there's this one I
really liked which was called forever
yours but yeah that I think came out
just really well out of the ones i
recorded so a friend of mine said that I
should go for the Christmas number one
in the UK which is kinda like the
biggest chart in the in the of the year
and a lot of big artists just really
songs to try and try and get there so i
announced his campaign on lines we're
going to get the crystal number one I
didn't think I'd actually get anywhere
close to it but I thought would be no
fun to try and ended up happening was
the music video went online and got it's
on I think five million views now I got
that one or two million initially and
when my song went live on iTunes it sold
100,000 copies around the world so and
it ya gots number one and broke a
guinness world record for the highest
charting single by an unsigned artist I
didn't expect any of those things and it
was like a real kind of kick start to my
to my career really with words before I
was just released an album and say the
album's out and that was just all I did
no no in a different vein here what is a
nerimon and well when i was 10 i wrote a
series of movies like fan fiction about
digimon their cartoon digimon and so i
thought i was in these obviously and i
had my own little digimon that i
invented who was called nerimon and it
was just the word that i made up so it
wasn't taken as a user name or anything
so whenever I used to sign up to
websites I would sign up as nerimon
because it was just a little unique word
and I never thought I'd have to explain
it to you know people like so many years
like in informal settings well now that
it's out there in the public now we all
know what it is you'll never hopefully
have to explain it again is yeah I like
that now you're kind of this you're a
very stylish kind of guy probably who
instead I mean who influences your style
um I don't know I don't have any one
particular person that I'm but I really
sort of look to their style inspiration
anything I've always just thought really
hard about the expressiveness of the
things I where Sir example like I worker
like patterns jeans and stuff typically
because most people express themselves
you like the top half they were like
really cool t-shirts and just plain
jeans and so I just thought well I want
to just express myself with all of my
body so I looked her like just kind of
quite vibrant jeans and stuff and I like
I like the idea of having shirts that
have things that shouldn't be on shirts
if that make sense like a teacher at
least be a map and and like a
composition notebook pattern this is
like a snakeskin kind of pan so yeah
that things that normally shouldn't be
warned no I like having those sordid I'm
thankful you pull it after that for the
whole roof of your your look and style
but who influences you musically then um
there's like I whenever I say specific
artists the most conscious of the fact
that some of those artists just have
songs I don't like so if I say like I
really like the beatles you know but I
don't like a lot of the Beatles stuff
and so like the Beatles doing brings me
a lot just the way they wrote melodies
and their song structures and things and
i really like Bruno Mars his first album
and so because my music is quite sort of
mainstream my guess like it's not it's
just quite catchy and commercial and
like fun and poppy so I listened to a
lot of mainstream stuff I guess to try
and see what people are doing and I'm oh
yeah so I like you know lady gaga I
really like Michael Jackson and hugely
so I'm as I'm learning more about music
production I'm kind of listening to his
stuff a lot and getting more from that
so yeah all right now you have a new
album it's epigrams and interludes and
that's kind of coming out soon right
yeah it's a much something so I mean
don't like give me a little more on that
like what are we gonna be seeing with
the album I mean is it kind of a what
style of music is it a departure from
your previous albums sure and what I
wanted to do because so after Forever
Yours happen i spent all of last year
just releasing individual tracks just
singles released one every two or three
months into her least about six and and
so that and it really started to work
for me this sort of singles model I
really liked it and so then in thinking
about why I'd ever release a full-length
thing again and eyes are going to really
like rethink about what it is that I get
out of
having an album or having a bullying
collection of stuff and the main thing
is that when you're trying to get into
an artist that you've just you've just
heard of the newest album is that is the
sort of reference point you don't look
at the last single they release that you
look at the last but full thing they put
out and to yeah so this is a real kind
of almost like a mixed tape of it's got
all of the singles from last year on it
yeah it's like it's like a good just
sort of like the best the best of what
has come before and then like the newest
things all in kind of one now i love i
love you have a your narrow man a
nirmaan a youtube channel is is pretty
fantastic you've got a lot of very
opinionated up posts and uploads that
you do and i love it i think it's great
you but you see my eject a lot of like
pop culture stuff like breaking bad new
organs i remember you did one where it
started like it was gonna be the Harlem
shake and then you said nope uh now we
have him an act or are you are you just
not about pop culture or um well with
the holiday thing I just thought didn't
see the point so I was just it was one
of those things where if everyone I knew
was just getting really annoyed by
seeing all these videos pop out of
square so I decided to just make my joke
was just I'd pretend I can do it and
then go not really cuz i am cool or
whatever um but yeah the breaking bad
thing is just like it's one of those
things that people are famous now for
evangelizing Breaking Bad and so I
thought it would be funny just too yeah
try and tell the internet as politely
okay can you please start having to
watch breaking bad please and so yeah
it's just my little ways it's kind of
having fun with my audience I guess more
than anything now do you feel like
YouTube I mean kind of going through
YouTube like you have you feel like it's
allowed you to be more successful than
maybe if you went through a more
traditional channel oh yeah yeah a
hundred sent like I am one of the things
that's most important to me is not
talking about music all the time because
that's what most musicians do when you
do but i just don't really I feel like
more people would benefit from just
making videos about other stuff because
I'm not just a musician like I'm not
just what I do and and if I only my
videos you know playing songs or talking
about my tour or my new album or
something then I feel like people would
only watch me
if they liked my music if they didn't
let me that they just wouldn't get
anything out of why I was doing whereas
now because I there are people that
don't like my music that might just be
entertained by me anyway they're going
to stick around and watch what I do and
then you know when I announced my new
album and it's like 499 on iTunes
they're like oh maybe i will pick that
up and it's just a good way of kind of
keeping people around I think yeah
you're definitely Anna like I said yeah
I enjoyed I enjoyed your calm and carry
and you're very funny but also kind of
crude sometimes you get catch any flack
from like the moms of the younger
viewers or the moms kind of fans too I
don't know if they know um like I feel
like when when you're watching YouTube
it's a very private thing like we you
look at video stats things like I'm
broadcasting to half a million people or
something but it's really not it's just
you know you're broadcasting to the one
person who's sitting on their computer
watching you so like I've always said
that my audience if they're going to see
if they're gonna kick on one of my
videos they should probably just put
headphones in just in case I like right
off the bat just just start off by
swearing really loudly or something and
so they're they're spittle trained and
he'll like it's one of my videos comes
out they could like just put the
headphones and I'll turn the volume down
and then it's like they're in kind of
secret little world fun oh speaking of
your fans have you had any like crazy
stalker stories yet wait oh okay so yeah
so once i was i was sitting at my old
flat we've moved houston out by used to
be this clap and i was in the living
area and we were on the ground floor we
had a little patio outside and then
beyond that was like a public footpath
there was a fence in between and row
bushes um so I was hitting him in the
living I was I had a bacon time we was
just about to bite into it and I looked
up and in the little common area just
behind the bushes there was a kid with
one of my band t-shirts on with a camera
just staring at me and I like locked
eyes with him and we just looked each
other for second and then he just slowly
just lowered himself down behind the
bushes until I couldn't see him anymore
really really creepy and I tweeted
saying this is not how you meet me can
we not can you not do that please and we
were planning to move any one place but
that was
moves per month after that but that was
weird because people it's always like
Where's Wally it's like the fact that
they found where I live they felt like
it was like a really cool thing and it
was okay to just be like you're really
awesome I mean like it's really like I'm
very flattered that you know they like
me and stuff but that's my little
private space like I haven't shared my
address with the world for a reason you
know now you're also in a band chameleon
circuit I believe and I guess wired at
one point noted that you guys could have
like several chart toppers and be a huge
band except you kind of go with this
really nerdy kind of silly content I
guess I'm saying like do you ever think
about like changing the content just to
kind of sell out let's say it here do
it's not know you could be big for you
know choosing not to be and I am yes
over in the fan right talking about the
the sci-fi show Doctor Who and it was me
it was really just like a fun side
project that we was just decided would
be fun to do and so we've released two
albums and that's yeah that that's its
own thing so if we were if we ever got
together to write songs that weren't
Doctor Who songs then we wouldn't be
chameleon circuit because that that's
what that project is designed to do
really but we were all of the members of
that band or individual musicians anyway
that released solo stuff so we have our
own air outlet for our own you know non
sci-fi TV show songs now on your website
you have the most amazingly bizarre
video of a naked man dancing in front of
a pirate screams favorite films how did
you find this video uh yeah I have a
friend round he's currently downstairs
playing limbo on the xbox and then she
said have you seen the video of the
naked guy dancing to the post Caribbean
and I said no come so she's choking it
and I decide it's got about 80 thousand
views appointments but a lot about three
months and I decided that I wanted to
make this the biggest thing in the world
because I've always really funny and so
um so I tweeted it I put it on Facebook
for it on tumblr i emailed a few friends
of mine and said can we please make this
as big as possible so yeah I guess I
didn't think about it from a
professional perspective if you go to my
blog but first thing you now sees and
making patent on sinks and pirates of
the caribbean but i just thought it
would be worth sharing yeah nice
I'm glad and sad that you did because
now I know about that but like it's
hilarious now we have a we SAT there we
kind of pitched on on Twitter that we
were going to be speaking with you and
so we have some excited fans and so of
course they picked some questions and we
grabbed a couple of them just to ask you
so small she box men rights pancakes
versus waffles thank you for starting
with such a hot day in question I I
shouldn't be thinking too much about it
pancakes okay good good now and then
Theo Joe right what's one quality or
characteristic every video someone
uploads should have or if there's more
than one oh I think just honesty because
I think if you're if you're trying to
make videos because you you want to be
famous or something like that then
people sort of noticed that and like the
Internet's very good at putting
integrity in people i think and shaming
them if they don't have it so yeah I
think just being honest about what
you're sharing now you have any plans to
tour to support the new album I actually
don't I am I I tend not to gig much
because my audience because of YouTube
my audiences you know global so if I
announce I'm doing like a tour of the UK
then all the comments are just people
not in the UK like oh well can't you
play why city so and so I'll do a tour
at some point when I can go to a lot of
the world at once I think that would be
really awesome and but now it's like the
equivalent I see its equivalent of when
you know people playing bars or ever
since to try and get noticed I just play
on the internet so I'm gonna keep doing
that and hope that it gets me here as
far as I can well since we're an
internet magazine I'm thrilled that
you've chosen to do that so Alex day
thank you very much for taking the time
to talk with us and like I said I'm
excited for the new album no no tool
thanks Manny Trillo that's Kathy know
for sure all right well you have an
excellent day and we'll talk later I
sleep cool ok all right thank you very
much
Pop's to scream some ways unprepared